i'm just going to go straight into it
really um so obviously it's a choice i
have to
pick a or pick b so would you i say
would you rather but it's to pick your
poison anyway
um kill your best friends kill your best
friend and get away with it
or b break into a sperm bank and drink
everything
so you basically have to kill me or
swallow nut it's basically what they're
asking
i love how it's and get away with it you
know
like the moral side of it has nothing to
do with it it's got nothing to actually
give him
he'll get away with it or drink nut the
whole sperm back
break into a sperm bank and drink
everything
ah
um
um
i mean i'm thinking about it it's an
easy decision i'm back in the nut
i'm back in the night i'll swallow at
home i'll have to i'll gluggle it from
i'll have to oh i'm not killing my boy
oh
i'm not killing my boy nothing not for
not for not for anything
because this is what you said about the
um we said earlier about the like
premeditated murder
you've done nothing to me yeah true
truth so what am i supposed to do just
roll up to you and just kill you
yeah nah i couldn't do that fair no
anger in my soul i just got to kill you
just to save me drinking some nut these
times i've had head before fam
i've had head before these lot
back it for for no reason
no rhyme or reason they're just
swallowing it hard i'm just here for it
and i'm willing to kill someone just so
i don't have to do it
for one day nah oh i will slurp the knot
i'll have to but it is what it isn't it
ma'am
we moved gee you're thank you you better
thank me
i'll take you to your face straight away
as soon as i as soon as i get out and
just
i'll say you owe me fat i'm like where
have you been if i'm waving
my son will be bloated it will be
gurgling
oh jesus i would vomit am i allowed
am i allowed to vomit during the process
it doesn't give me any
um what's the word i'm looking for it
doesn't give me any um
rules or regulations it just says this
or that just this or that just this or
that okay you can you can do it you can
do what you want so as long as i can
vomit
whilst i'm then doing it will happily do
it
they could never tell me you're not
allowed to be sick because that's how i
was in my control yeah
of course i'm going to be [ __ ] sick
oh
i'm gonna stink i will stink
i'm i hope i can can i wash it down do
you know
just think i know you don't know from
there okay okay can i wash it down the
water
okay um i think after let's say
let's say the sperm bank has about 100
vials in there
so you can swig a bit of water after
every ten
ten files yeah not as thick fam
what if it cut like i said you need to
tap the bottom
oh that's the wish let's make this shake
oh
i have to do that ten times before i can
get one sip of water yeah and then i go
again for another
you can have a bottle of water you can
have as much as water as you can
physically stomach before you go in yeah
and you can just take me as long as it
takes me i just got to get through it
yeah yeah
or you can kill me someone needs to
hypnotize me fam i'd need to think of
syrup or satin
speaking of it'll probably make me wham
i am
was uh listening to an interview with
asa akira
okay the porn star yeah and she said
that
there was a time when she was in her
prime
she was inhaling and
in taking so much nut that she was
starting to exhibit like male symptoms
like uh like a little bit of like hair
on her neck and face like thick hairs
coming through on her neck and face
yeah fam and like i can't remember what
other other stuff was but uh maybe like
a question or something i don't know
but she was getting like she got like
blood tests and stuff and uh her
testosterone level was was higher than
it should be no way
just from all the nuts she had in her
wow
that's a lot enough i would think about
that the whole time
so that's why i'm banging gym after this
i'm banging gym after this i'll convince
myself i want to be here
[Laughter]
this is what i have to do certain man
have to drink breast milk to get one i'm
willing to
to slurp nah it is what is
wow but yeah i it's it's not fun
it's not a fun way to live your life but
i wouldn't i wouldn't kill you but would
you you'd kill me in it
would i wouldn't kill i'd have to do i'd
have to drink the nut because i'm the
same thing
it's not pre-meditated i've got no anger
or no manage towards you to kill you so
it's not something i'd want to do you
know yeah but
i wouldn't i wouldn't drink it imagine
imagine you did that for me and i
bullied you afterwards
i laughed in your face after swallowing
a hundred dollars
i was like i should have killed me waste
man you dave bastard
we can never speak again we can never
speak again after that i'll be sorry
fam i'd be so livid you could never tell
me i would say what were the
circumstances
you could ever tell me that fam you
don't know what i've just been through
i'm like what what
what happened said someone wrote up to
me and said i'm going to kill james
if you don't clean this spur bank
i said you believed it
[Laughter]
imagine i would be or imagine at the end
he was like
pigmen how was i gonna with what method
i don't know him
i've never met him i'm a fan of the pods
oh
and you just i'm just there bloated
sperm dripping down my lips i don't want
how was i going to get away with this
murder anyway
you didn't think it through for you i
didn't think it through
i said i say fam did he hold a gun to
your head you just said nah
he just threatened your life he didn't
threaten my friend
yeah he just threatened your life and i
just i had to jump
i just backed it i didn't think again
jesus imagine that's disgusting
that is very disgusting cool man well um
yeah that's the poison i picked the nut